this episode is sponsored by keeps
oh god it's summer ah yes the summer sun
is shining down
the school kids are off on their holiday
the god damn loud our cicadas
are having a great [ __ ] time and we
get to enjoy some more seasonal anime
now i know we've got some high
expectations coming into this i mean how
can't you
i said in spring that following the
winter anime season was like having a
boxing match right after muhammad ali
just stepped out of the ring little did
i know that [ __ ] mike tyson was going
to show up out of nowhere so what do we
have in store for the summer are we
going to get sugar ray johnson or is
logan paul going to be entering the ring
either way my hopes are high so is
summer going to continue this year's
hype train or we're just gonna get an
absolute train
[Applause]
well this is awkward
all right connor open white
after the tragedy of the arsenal attack
just about two years ago it feels so
good to see kyoto animation coming back
at their absolute breasts best and what
an absolute statement they've made
god [ __ ] down i came here for a
wholesome little slice of life and i
opened things up with a fight scene that
went so hard it would make most shonen
battle anime quake in their boots i
don't normally like to talk about
sequels too much in these videos but god
damn it's good to have you back kyoto
animation but before we get this season
fully started a quick word from our
sponsor good evening weebs do you know
what i care about
my hair even with the fact that i was a
monk before that's relevant now well
thankfully this episode is sponsored by
keeps did you know that two out of three
guys will experience male pattern
baldness by the age of 35
and i may not look like it but i'm one
of those guys
every single man in my family has gone
bold and i knew this so while it might
look like i'm the exception
i've put in a lot of work behind the
scenes to keep
my hair the way it is do you see what i
did there keeps is a subscription
service that focuses on making it easier
and more affordable for men to treat
their male pattern baldness online
a licensed doctor can review all your
information online recommend
you the best treatment plan and then
send you that plan every three months
keeps offers all the generic versions of
the fda approved drugs to keep
all the costs down i really didn't do
that on purpose the treatments take
between four to six months to start
seeing results so it's important that
you start
acting now because look if you're like
me and you've known for years that
you're gonna go bold then the only thing
you can do to combat that
is to stop it before it happens once the
hair is gone
it's gone for good and that's exactly
what keeps is and look i normally try to
keep these sponsorships anime related
but i really do wish i had a service
like keeps when i started looking into
this
years ago so if saitama from one punch
man isn't the look that you want to go
for then go to keeps.com for 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash giggup for fifty percent
off your first order
or just click the link in the
description anyway back to the video hey
boss have you heard of this one
what okay edward elrick walks into a bar
he says has anyone seen my metal arm i
really need help finding it
barman says don't worry edward i'll
definitely give you
a hand
i don't get it god what an edgy mess
this is you've got brutal violence
crazy anime girls there's some rabbit
that looks like she just walked straight
out of one piece
autocad was finally done with being a
taxi driver
and now he's just a mass murderer it
seems to be the show that seems to be
run entirely on edgy anime logic like
you have the usual goody two-shoe
protagonists doing the good thing and
breaking this girl out joe because the
mean guards are bullying this poor
defenseless anime girl
except the girl actually just brutally
murdered dozens of soldiers like five
minutes ago and she literally saw her
brutally murdered dozens of soldiers
like five minutes ago
and for some reason she's completely
okay with her brutally murdering like
dozens of soldiers like five minutes ago
because just look at her
she's a cute anime waifu there is no
such thing as a if you're looking for
some mindless violence set in that same
[ __ ] fantasy world then yeah you'll
probably enjoy akami no isekai i lied
it's not actually an isa guy yo wait did
someone say he said god oh for [ __ ] as
if you know isaac
has somewhat been taking over the modern
anime scene in recent years but
thankfully if you're one of the ones
who's been a bit tired of that
this season we only have one two three
four
five six seven eight new izakaya airing
this season
so um pretty slow season for isakai
overall villainous is on season two same
with i'm standing on one million lives
slime two is continuing and i'll say if
you've been sleeping on slime two
because you think it'll be the same feel
good wholesome show as it was in season
one
all i'll say to you is that you better
catch up because it's kicking off
then we go with a new easter car which
let me tell you how it's gonna go down
okay well i mean okay well the
protagonist is gonna do it
stop taking my job i know we're way past
the point of self-aware isekai's story
since connoisseur did it [ __ ]
five years ago are you serious but
tsukimichi's got a pretty strong attempt
at it you've got a guy who's actually
the child of some isekai immigrants
who's been sent to the world of his
parents where he meets a goddess who
looks at him with contempt because
compared to every other easy guy
hiroki's
really ugly what and so she sends him to
the fancy world with the weakest and
most useless powers she can think of
the ability to understand any language
instantly
[Music]
there's an isekai called drugstore in
another world about a guy who opens a
drugstore in another world
you know at this point i'm just waiting
for some guide to get transported to a
fantasy world and then decide to open up
the local [ __ ] nandos i mean what the
[ __ ] is next
capitalism in another world
they're really doing capitalism in
another world how a realist hero rebuilt
the kingdom okay this one's actually all
right there's no overpowered
protagonists no grand adventure just a
guy trying to save the fantasy kingdom
via the two sexiest words in the world
politics and economics okay i know that
sounds a lot like slime without
the slime so it has even less of a hook
but this one goes way more in depth with
the technicalities of how it goes about
achieving everything
so if you've ever thought hey i want to
spy some more fisa guy
well here you go
here's a curveball for you how about a
dark comedy about a cynical pessimistic
children's show presenter who's had
enough of life
slowly losing his [ __ ] mind on camera
in front of a bunch of playful kids
i'm on the fence about this one on one
hand this is totally my type of cynical
comedy but a guy with zero [ __ ] to give
in front of some clueless children and
boom easy comedy but on the other hand
i'm not sure how you're gonna keep this
concept fresh for an entire season
because not every joke in the first
episode hit but at the very least we
could have a laugh at some guy losing
the will to go on because of some
children i mean
come on they're just kids what's the
worst thing they can say
i'm not gonna lie summer season had a
lot to live up to we're coming off the
back of two of the best anime seasons in
recent memory but so far
we've kind of just had a lot of this if
there is one show to look up for the
season however
it's sunny boy sometimes all it takes is
a few seconds for a show to immediately
stand out from the crowd and right away
you can probably tell
sunnyboy ain't just your typical anime
you've got a school that's been sent to
some kind of pocket dimension a group of
kids are trying to figure out how to
govern themselves this guy just starts
breaking the entire [ __ ] space-time
continuum we've got some mind-bending
animation and imagery the whole thing
looks like a satoshi khan movie with a
bit of yuasa flair oh
and every kid's been given a different
superpower in this place as well
this can only end well this is a lord of
the flies type anime original show
coming from shingo natsume who if you
aren't familiar directed this
and this
and it feels like he's been given total
freedom to do whatever he wants which
could mean this could turn out to be a
fully realized vision with no compromise
or an absolute [ __ ] mess maybe both
anime originals though have been
absolutely killing it this year with
shows like odd taxi
bv megalo box wondering
anime originals though have been kind of
killing it this year so i've got high
hopes that this could bloom into
something great
i gotta be honest i saw this as one of
the top shows of the season with light
level readers hyping this up so i came
in with high hopes and
honestly it was pretty whelming you've
got a terrorist threatening to blow up a
plane unless this female ace detective
can deduce the reason of his hijacking
what follows is the most [ __ ]
hello i'm a smart anime character
monologue i've seen in a while as from a
single
[ __ ] line she's able
[Music]
okay now explain the entire fate
franchise to me
but now i [ __ ] know where it turns
out the guy is actually a ghoul but it's
okay because she managed to bring a
[ __ ]
gun on board but please no liquids over
300 milliliters so we get this dope ass
fight scene she wins the fight saves the
day then eats the most anemic pizza i've
ever seen in my life
oh please give that pizza some [ __ ]
cheese i beg of you
cool action aside i think what bothered
me the most was just the bland ass
dialogue between the detective and the
main protagonist
it's like someone saw the character
dynamics of bakamunagatri or bunnygirl
senpai and went yeah
we got that at home it tries so hard to
emulate that same kind of chemistry
without capturing the same charm or wit
this feels like it's so close to being a
decent show so i'll probably give this
one a few more episodes to see if it
actually fires his footing and actually
gets me to care about what's going
on
[Music]
i'm making [ __ ] mac n cheese and
nobody can stop you know i should
probably be more hyped about this than i
am i mean it's a new
studio bones anime that looks like it
was made by studio bones with the yuki
kajara soundtrack i'm not a huge fan of
vampires or the setting
or the premium proper pretty boys who
look like they speak exclusively in
times new roman nothing too much about
the plot has grouped me in the beginning
episode so i'll just have to wait and
see if this is something that goes truly
above and beyond we've got a water polo
anime for those of you who've ever
thought okay
imagine kuroko but wet and i mean who
doesn't love a bit of wet kuroka i mean
look at this [ __ ]
it's so wet in here the ducks and geese
are gonna migrate to the sahara desert
it's so wet in here we're about to set
up some tsunami warnings it's so wet in
here i thought
i thought god eb dropped a [ __ ] [ __ ]
somewhere nearby
pa works have a new anime set in an
aquarium this time
i'm under the water please help me
you're too much really
you know i've always been a bit wary of
pa works anime nowadays because without
fail they look visually stunning and
aqua type on the white sand
is absolutely no exception this is
probably one of the most beautiful
looking new shows of the season but then
you look at their track records and for
every gorgeous masterpiece they create
they can make an equally gorgeous just
as highly polished piece of turd
you know what still some pretty good
looking turds out there though i'm sure
a lot of people have had that
existential realization that you're just
not doing exactly what you want to be
doing in life that you took the wrong
path somewhere and you should have gone
a different direction and that's exactly
what this anime
is about hashiba is a 28 year old guy
who wishes he could be working in the
creative industry instead of getting a
boring degree and becoming an office
worker
so one day when he wakes up in a younger
body with a chance to redo it all he has
just one
thought i gotta invest in bitcoin no
of course he doesn't do anything smart
like buying apple stocks or
uninstalling league of legends but
instead he shoots for his dreams by
going
to art school wait that's illegal you
know ignoring the obvious things you
would do if you actually traveled back
in time with knowledge of the future
this is actually an interesting concept
if you've ever thought you've wanted to
go back in time to redo a major aspect
of your life then you might find
something in here
[Music]
so let me get this straight this anime
is about a guy who gets a girlfriend and
gets confessed to by another girl but
doesn't want to reject the other girl so
he unlocks 100 of his brain
and decides that the best solution to
this problem is just
simply two-time so he asks his
girlfriend he cleaned up another
girlfriend and she goes no and he goes
yes and she goes no and he goes yes and
she goes no and he goes no and she goes
yes
haha no take backs so they all agree to
engage in a three-way relationship with
each other and then on top of that
immediately decide to move in with each
other what an
absolute mess of a situation
alright hear me out this is a show that
absolutely shouldn't work
but for some reason it does it's a harem
anime that actually follows through
with the harem part there is no best
girl cause every girl wins
yes even the short-haired blue one and
honestly
i'm not sure how i feel about that i
mean they're clearly setting unrealistic
expectations for anime fans showing a
guy getting
two girlfriends when most weebs can't
even get what works about this is just
how stupidly upfront and honest everyone
is about this
and the great thing is you'll only need
the same number of brain cells as these
guys have collectively to be able to
enjoy this show
which is three somehow it's so stupid
that i can make you forget how
[ __ ] the entire situation is that you
can just laugh at it that's right
who needs chivalry when you can dabble
in some casual polygamy
don't please don't quote me on that it's
funny it's turn your brain off fun and
because of this
it's the most awful anime ever made
the characters are stupid it's really
unrealistic and no guy in the right mind
would ever try what the main character
is doing because he's a stupid dum-dum
that nobody should idolize especially
not me
is that okay
[Music]
i did not hit her it's not true holy
[ __ ] am i seeing this right
nagatoro but but milf
it's it's milf nagatoro
i didn't think we could improve on
perfection but the mad lads did it
finally anime is starting to realize
what we
really want finally the best
tags are getting some representation we
are getting the sexy anime girls we
truly deserve
dark-skinned tanned milf
does it get any better than this no
degeneracy here
only culture gentlemen it is time
the revolution has begun perfection
is here i can now declare
without a shadow of a doubt the best
and sexiest girl of 2021
has been found and her name ill
my god she's a lolly
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much to
levados manopla pony stark dysfunctional
degenerate
alpha sigma jeff ivito the walter
payne patchett elephant basil and
everyone else my patreon for helping to
support me for this month and making
this video possible
you know i'm kind of glad that the
season's a bit slow because
i can finally catch up to all the anime
i'm behind on who am i kidding i'm never
catching up for anime
but yeah i'll be sure to keep my eyes
out to see if there are any sleep hits
this season though in the meantime i am
going to be traveling back to england
briefly in the next month so i'm not
sure what the video making situation is
going to be
but keep your eyes peeled because i
gotta figure that out myself not going
for anywhere too long
just going to visit friends and family
then fly back here
god that feels so weird to say anyway
that's it from me
no further updates today i've been
gig-uk and i'll see you all
next time